oh this is so cute I just opened up this
box it's like a big box and I was like
what the heck is this and I pulled out a
van it's really cute it's so cute it's
got like little fake stickers all over
it like I'd rather be Cal it opens the
door opens this is incredible so this is
from Mophie know when you see this Jenna
oh no way yes way
no way yes way I think that they may
have saw my Instagram comment because
then I saw the faith released what is
inside of here I freaked out I was like
oh my god oMG it's like a real classic
hydrastine move like hyped super what's
in it right who's got the keys to the
van beep-beep let's see what's back here
this is where the goods are Oh cute and
thoughtful look at this in it look at
this charger oh my yes it's beautiful I
know it is gold this thing is ridiculous
you can basically charge everything I
love as they put it in like a little
camper van because this also has a
little outlet so that you can like plug
in a computer or are the things that you
would need to power with like an actual
weight this is perfect for camping I
know
Oh AC adapter baby it is Wireless I was
just gonna say I think that's actually a
wireless charger well it's not on but
push them out pal how's the button oh
I'm has a flashlight shook this is
exactly what I need jump your car I know
but we should oh my gosh it does it says
jumpstart
okay this is incredible okay well let's
turn this on and just charge our basic
phone go ahead put that up there I love
that this has different buttons for each
section to charge what else is in here
oh no wait
plug jumper cables into your power
station go and attach jumper cable
clamps to car battery I was I was like
joking like I thought that's what it was
for but that's insane this is actually
super useful it comes with it can you
imagine my car dies which it has because
actually one time left it on by accident
and I didn't for days it was a long time
and I went out to my car and it was
great but out of both feet I would
medical triple-a this is genius it's
unreal I'm very much so on board this
Mophie life I'm probably going to be
asking to borrow this because I do these
under canvas a lot and then I got a BYOB
this is even cooler than I thought I
honestly was just into it because I
thought it was a massive pattern of it I
could just make tic TOCs
oh oh there's mommy this could also be
used for lighting if you're like you
know camping you're like oh I need some
Lightning it can also be used to make
tic TOCs like to light yourself for
tick-tock what else we got in there I
think that's everything but look how
cute this little van is I mean it
actually is everything Oh No look
there's something else
Oh Marge in the car you can charge this
in the car and then you can use this to
charge your car oh my goodness that's
that's a full circle not a fool
that's a 360 baby this is incredible
I'm onboard reggae this is a very very
quick video because I just really wanted
to show you guys how awesome this
presentation is like I'm shook
absolutely this is so it's very cute I
can't believe I can jump my car with us
I wish we have like a little cutout to
put like of you in there I'd probably be
the driver Jew realist secondly put you
to me over here where this fur doesn't
open okay so look at so when Triple A
came out to jump my car they couldn't
find the battery and they were like
where's your battery I said I don't know
was it like a secret place I don't
remember I think it's under the
passenger side seat it's a really great
story this is the future
you can jump your car with a multi
battery they have a blue a black Oh a
gold a rose gold they also have a camo
one the blue and camo the camel was this
the one that I saw and I was like that's
what I was like me the blue has my name
all over it oh the rose gold this is
insane the fact that this is $160 and
you can jump-start a vehicle I can
roadtrip believe it yeah I'm excited
this I'm proof jumper cables LED light
USB a 65 watt AC port wireless charging
unconnect connects and charge multiple
devices it's easy and safe to use
forty-four thousand four hundred
megawatt hour battery like that's oh my
god this is insane
I've already started to charge it cuz
we're going on a road trip we're going
on a road trip
[Music]